tous
[Musique]
une salle de boxe comme une autre à
brooklyn non pas vraiment une salle de
boxe comme une autre amum coco mais new
york ou fort-de-france l'énergie est la
même une énergie qui ici aussi produit
des champions
valérie est l'une des stars au mas
dynamique boxing club elle est double
championne de france de kick boxing day
one est de montrer comment on peut faire
des champions et du championnat les
femmes
serait-elle en train de prendre le
pouvoir dans nos salles de boxe la même
salle deux heures plus tôt pour beaucoup
de ces boxeurs c'est jour de rentrée
voire même leur premier contact avec ce
sport ils ont entre 8 et 14 ans et vous
l'aurez constaté beaucoup beaucoup de
filles dans cette salle et elle aime ça
[Musique]
ça sert à quoi la boxe défendre à
l'école c'est moi qui vous le pentax
pourquoi tout à défendre à l'école oui
c'est pas simplement pour les garçons
ceci pour les filles pourquoi pourquoi
on pourra pas faire papa séparé sport
pour les garçons parce qu'on se bat dans
ce club pas de différence entre hommes
et femmes entre garçons et filles
cette forme de boxe est en réalité du
tout boxing kiwan mélange de boxe
thaïlandaise et de kickboxing japonais
poings pieds genoux sont des armes
santonnière son adversaire et sans
protection
[Musique]
il y en a beaucoup
enfin pas que des femmes il ya beaucoup
d'adhérents qui viennent d'abord dans le
but de
de faire du car audio simplement
transpirer quoi et qui après se prennent
au jeu parce qu'ils voient que bon en
fait les idéaux insu en fait ne sont pas
du tout ce qui a à ce qui ce qui se
passe en fait que caf peut venir
pratiquer la boxe soient protégés donner
des coups et ça se fait dans un bon état
d'esprit
et voilà l'histoire d'une salle de boxe
en pleine semaine et en début de soirée
salle de champions où l'énergie est la
même que l'on soit à new york ou à mon
coco